how's Goomer as mine is purely bad as
you know the team from as above so below
sent me to Paris to do the catacombs
challenge it was absolutely horrible but
I made it out alive
hallelujah I also got to see the film
while I was in Paris and yeah it wasn't
that scary the goal for the catacombs
challenge was to find three keys in
there and I had to use them to open the
container which held the philosopher's
stone when you're watching the footage
remember for me it was pitch-black down
there all right there's a bunch of
infrared cameras and stuff like that so
you can see in the dark for you bros but
sort of a it was hard a lot but yeah
this is all a very cool experience I
really really hope you bros enjoy this
video here we go
this way yes okay
Oh God all right
cozy because it
is it always this dark do I have anyone
okay
good seriously
isn't really far down
are you gonna stay with me the whole
time
cuz I'm okay with that oh thank you
what uh what what the hell okay Jesus
Christ
how's it goin brace this is pure pie I'm
gonna go to catacombs if there's no
light do not move okay and the ceiling
are a bit low okay
do not run the ground is uneven okay I'm
ready at all I'm already I already go
yeah
I want to go that Oh
okay it's okay it's just a video game
except it's not like a die that's not oh
jesus guys almost bad wonderful
no no this right here
no what is this okay I'm just gonna say
yeah
what is this
I didn't know why
thank Jesus what
J'son right environment oh Jesus
okay I almost died but I'm okay it's a
really pretty French guy I think you
might want to date me wait you never
know I'm I'm occupied so yes - no booth
you know don't do that again please
so I guess I have a light so it's all
about cutting hello anyone in here hello
that's my name but I don't trust you
okay that's light here I would cheat
don't laugh oh god what is this what is
this okay think we have to investigate
this okay no don't don't do anything my
neck is I'm very vulnerable and okay fly
and stuff
okay maybe I should check here even more
there's an others oh come on
okay what does it say here there is or
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
thanks that's really helpful a key
resides in get dammit all right then
we're gonna have to do this
I hate these I do this at kindergarten
ones and I rural life that it's all
coming okay it's better not be it okay I
don't I don't want
oh okay let's go Chris I have to check
oh thank you
screw that y'all goddamn it what is that
hello
that was all day okay escameca don't be
alive please oh okay he's dead myself
did you dead people am I supposed to
check the day maybe he has something man
hello they're dead here you look great
today it's a camera what are you taking
selfies it's hard to say but you're not
very ugly
we're probably
Oh No
no it's camera sex Oh God are you
serious no huh no huh
or miscible okay okay I'm shaking like a
vibrator right now and that's okay
is there action that's great that some
pictures on you very pretty
okay
electric see let's go that's okay that's
great that you're down with that I just
really need to go this way okay
no no no okay Jesus waited oh you're a
dance that's great
okay
it's kind of me okay kids yes kind of go
through this and then I'm gonna go have
hot chocolate Jacqueline
it's definitely stuff happening it's
like water
thing down there and this like stones
nugget I put my hand out there alright
it's not gonna be anyone down there
hello
appreciator two keys
Jesus comments how long was that
my legs are he's okay
I have turkeys that's my friend don't
have any light though I don't even mean
I thought okay that'd be done turkeys I
would kiss it but it's kind of gross all
right yes I'm coming I'm coming
don't you worry okay just don't kill me
please again there's a shadow there and
I like this okay let's just be careful
hello
hi hi Rufus I don't know can I trust you
bro okay I don't know what kind of drugs
it was on but he was scary out of it
that was a sweet breakfast okay I'm
gonna keep going now please don't get me
just I like life like he said life is
why I miss Rosie okay that way I guess
that's gonna do that all right
Jesus Christ so Tori get on him
all right breasts I want you to know if
I don't make it out of life I love you
give my YouTube channel to my pugs Edgar
don't give anything to Edgar I don't
like it here
but that's not his fault I want them
okay
hello
oh what the [ __ ]
what that [ __ ]
he has something for me it's gonna be
okay
like you
[ __ ] can you read that according to
mythology that's the inscription home in
the case of how police should be made to
come on their beliefs and think you
don't I'm Sheila